that's how they should do it there
should be one producer per couple that's
trying to get them to win yes 100 there
should be a b show where it's all about
these dudes like and their psychology
yeah trying to make them win yeah
[ __ ] we should make that that's a really
good idea the show is just called the
producers that's kind of like um
there's already a show called that but
that's kind of like suicide squad
it is but
no one has to die in this one and it's
also like cabin in the woods sort of too
it is i like that but it'd be real yeah
and they could die too that's what i'm
saying they could die yeah we can make
it kind of like a yeah like a violent
yeah
death island death island
that's good
one of you will die by the end of this
we don't know who
happy [ __ ]
that'd be hilarious the producer like
okay come on come on come on i can't
give you the numbers we're [ __ ] down
we're down like bad here's a spear okay
what here's the here's the spirit
literally the only way use it when you
need to you'll know when
oh come on sorry
who is it
dude when you call me like this you
seriously give me the [ __ ] ick
don't do this
sorry mizad
um
no
imagine a couple is down in the polls
and then a pr the producer has a spear
and they're like there's no way we're
winning
this couple's in first just kill one of
them yeah they can't win yeah if one of
them's dead but they're so in love they
love each other so much right through
the neck
i don't care just pick one
yeah you won't you won't even feel
anything just do it it's fine it's
totally fine maritime laws that's why we
bought this island can't be persecuted
it's totally cool yeah
you know that that'd be so funny imagine
that being one of the questions that
they asked on the show that you vote in
the app yeah what does tyler sound like
getting top it's like ah ooh no it's not
multiple choices like insert voice note
[Music]
[Laughter]
quite nice yeah quite nice
that's english dudes pulling their
penises out before sex quite nice isn't
it
not really
no
no it's all right don't think
oh do not think
no it's not i can't believe you've said
this it's just all right i know it's
gone soft
oh no it's really gone off isn't it yeah
um click on the vote count link yeah say
like how much millie and liam won by is
pretty incredible
milliam received 42
of the votes landslide while runners-up
chloe and toby got 30
fan teddy narrowly snuck into third with
14
and kaz and tyler came forth with 12
percent of the votes
twitter mob who skewed votes
supposedly
how an online gang of 20-somethings
hijacked reality tv's best show what the
[ __ ] is there just like an like uh is
this like 4chan no what was the what was
the group that affected the winner is
gushing granny
what who's the group that affected the
election
oh oh that british company yeah um eight
something
isn't it
no that's 8chan that i'm thinking about
no not age
cambridge analytica yeah that's it yeah
kane bridge eight you can see wow it's
all their kids yeah all the kids are the
people who started cambridge analytics
yeah we will make sure
milliam wins they're buying facebook
campaigns about like how negative
or like how like how bad jake and
liberty are yeah and
trying to get them broken up on the show
and
but what is it how did it
it's
500 is the name it's a group of tweeters
on twitter called fiat 500 which is a
car that girls
really enjoy and so it's just a large
group of girls on twitter
who are big fans of millie like they're
in a big group chat
no they all sign their tweets with an ex
as a way to like distinguish themselves
and no that's just
that's just british people dude yeah
hugs and kisses
hog zinke says
i think the worst part about all this is
that jake never got to couple up with
liam which i think is what he was really
hoping for on the show yeah
that's why he was so distraught no down
to end it that's why he was like we're
you sure okay we can go our separate
ways because he's gay
could be who knows
i
don't even think there needs to be a
label yeah what he does know is that
part of him is for liam yeah
yeah yeah them dudes
they broke up and liam's like
jake single
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
i really want to get to know him yeah
really i'm having my doubts
that was a good impression
there's one person who's yeah
who i want to kiss on the mouth
his piercing blue eyes his piercing
liam your brown eyes your brown eyes
your wonderful nose
old compliment blue contacts your
wonderful leg sleeve
which compliments
your ripped thighs perfectly
i honestly think jake is gonna have the
worst time
after this i feel like in a year he's
gonna be like love island ruin my life
no you know what go to his instagram is
he chilling i was reading comments on
his instagram the other day and
everyone's like they did you dirty
people you were so misunderstood so i
think that people thought that his
intentions were
uh actually very sincere oh okay um
hugo dude
what are you doing man hugo seems like
no one actually likes him i know
he was so misunderstood absolutely love
jake i think the edits did him dirty see
i could see him hurting and it's such a
shame as i thought they were matched
perfectly yeah but now all right all
right it was really sad to watch over
the past several weeks can we find a
negative one that's my favorite thing to
do
dig through all the positivity just for
can't believe you didn't fight for her
she absolutely loved you and adored you
okay
all right
be kind
[ __ ] yeah
it's helpful when people remind you to
do that i mean i think the world would
be a little bit better a better place if
more people hashtagged be kind yeah
on instagram yeah
um
the difference between okay okay here we
go here we go
people doing homework
the difference between jake at the
beginning of f
f run on sentence
bit as [ __ ] poor introduction
red circle uh
um
around the ellipses punctuation question
mark yeah
he was drained even from casa too long
why what drained him you've already
jumped points you haven't even you
haven't even elaborated on your first
yeah what do you mean he was drained
hugo that's what you should do you
should just take all the negative
comments that bash you
and and grade them that's your youtube
channel yeah
all right for another punctuation
knockout round
here's a negative comment hugo
you're so [ __ ] annoying well first
you haven't spoke you're right
secondly incorrect tense
see that would work
that's a great idea
thanks man
yeah that's for hugo that's that's for
you brother
are there any other hugo
uh tick tocks that we can watch
before we go
okay
well i'll just go [ __ ] myself then